[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello and
welcome to Google I/O 2018.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
your host and one
of your guides for all things
I/O over the next three days.
We're so happy you're joining
us for our outdoor developer
festival here in Mountain
View, California.
We're getting ready for
the keynote to begin.
Before we take our seats,
inside the amphitheater,
I'd like to share a few
things we're doing differently
this year.
Because millions of viewers
like you joined us remotely last
year, we've decided to create a
bigger show just for you every
day of I/O. Now this
means when you're tuned
in to google.com/io, you'll
essentially have an all-access
pass for the entire festival.
You'll tour dozens
of Sandboxes with me
and your other guides
Todd, and Florina.
You'll also take a
stroll down Main Street
to check out all the
cool installations there.
Plus, you'll get special
access to interviews
with Googlers and I/O
guests and a front row
seat to the concert.
This year, the French
electronic music duo, Justice,
will take the stage on
Wednesday at 8:30 PM.
All of this will be happening
right here on google.com/io.
So keep this window open.
In just a few minutes, we'll
head into the amphitheater
where you'll join the on-site
attendees for our pre-show
and two awesome AI experiments.
First, a music performance
using NSynth Super,
which is a synthesizer
that generates new
sounds using neural
networks and World Draw,
a new, interactive
experience we want all of you
to take part in.
You'll join the rest of the
global developer community
to draw the world together
in real time using
the same technology behind
Quick, Draw and AutoDraw.
But before we get
to that, here's
a rundown of today's show.
Set your alarms now for 10:00
AM and 12:45 PM Pacific time.
That's when our Google and
developer keynotes begin.
You don't want to miss those.
Now after each
keynote, we'll share
a recap of the announcements
with some special guests.
In the breaks
between the sessions,
we'll head to the Sandbox
for some hands on fun.
I'll also be
sharing some stories
that will change
the way you look
at artificial intelligence.
It's a very full day.
We're just about 40 minutes
away from the keynote
and I can feel the
excitement growing.
But before we go, I'd
like to give a quick shout
out to the 450 extended
viewing parties
joining us from
around the world.
Welcome.
It's great to have you all here.
Remember to share photos of
your viewing party with us
on our Google+ I/O
extended community page.
And let us know which
announcements excite
you the most this year and why.
Please use hashtag #io18extended
with all your shares.
For everyone else, join the
conversation at hashtag #io18.
Also to get more information
on different Google Developer
products throughout the year, be
sure to take 30 seconds to sign
up at g.co/dev/form.
Now, let's join everybody in the
amphitheater for the pre-show.
Remember, I'll be here right
after the keynote for a recap
and more I/O at Google I/O 2018.
Enjoy the show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]